ok ich das internet
viola da was geht hier vor cani und
heute gibt es mal wieder ein ründchen
war training zusammen mit dem lieben und
dass man internet vielleicht einfach
funktioniert werden die aufnahmen es
wäre ja schön dass wir recht nicht von
der hand zu weisen aber zum glück hat er
kein schwert an
bei hat mich einfach so ab dass einfach
nicht mehr justin hat ziemliche intern
probleme wir müssen unbedingt hoffen
dass die bsv weg sind was aber
wahrscheinlich relativ unwahrscheinlich
ist also müssen uns da irgendeine lösung
überlegen irgendwas kreatives also oder
von telekom wenn jetzt zuschaut
transporter internet sticks heute mag
wir spielen einfach so lange was
zusammen bis wir zehn minuten voll haben
wir dich sagen weil wir machen jetzt
sowieso immer dass wir beim training
alles so nehmen wie es kommt
ok ich dachte weißt du bist nicht
angegriffen aber ich bin ich wir sind in
der tiefe der läuft zieht sich erst mal
ganz still haben also wollte die angst
nehmen bei mir hat sich auch im inventar
was wolltest du gern nehmen
schauen wir weiter bisher wird es ganz
gut ich bin zufrieden aber eigentlich
müssen wir angeln und so was wieder
weglassen was bestimmt konnten
allerdings interview angeschaut oder ja
natürlich alter ich habe das ganz schön
lange guckt alter über krass jeder kann
einfach komplett vernichtet ich sehe es
aber deshalb mega unfreundlich dem
reporter gegenüber korrekt zu dem ich
naja ich finde unterbricht ihn immer so
und lässt sie nicht los lässt ihn der
reporter berichten immer mehr weil russ
alter das generell über der abverkauf
ich finde das gehört es ganze projekt
ein kriegt ja ja ja auf jeden fall
völlig arafat über bossa dann hat er zu
hause gemerkt wie größe über respekt bei
dem aber ich finde er hat auch so
ich weiß nicht wann immer so gesagt so
jack alarm wenn irgendeine frage
gestellt sie mich willst du die er nicht
beantworten und so was also der hat
irgendwie von nichts zurückgeschreckt
hat war alles verkehr gehabt ins
unterhalt mit beweisen kontoauszügen und
anzeigen und very nice
was ist das eigentlich das verlieren von
carlo oder pink jetzt irgendwas nein
denn combo ubs ist komplett eigentlich
deutsch
natürlich gehen wir die nächste runde
das war dann nichts für mich zu gewinnen
deshalb kommentiere ich es gar nicht
weiter bis zum etwa super ja ich bin das
ich treibe here car porn chic ist ich
habe wirklich seit drei jahren gefühlt
keinen kurs gespielt jetzt kommen
wahrscheinlich experten sagen größe gibt
es noch keinen dreier
ich hatte damals nämlich auch richtig
ist ich hatte so eine alphaversion gar
nicht einfach
louis gallois der firma was für ein
glück ich habe richtig schlechte jetzt
gegeben da drin ist noch ein ludwig ich
muss aufpassen
wie bist du erst unterwegs irgendwie
bist du mir was dann werde ich es weg
pro monat anhalten versuchen lauter zu
reden
danach war eine hose
danke da wollte ich eine habe gefragt ob
es noch eine hast machst wirst du selbst
ein an
nein alles wieder aus ihren leggins
einfach das kinn
so aber ich irgendwie es ist rückt immer
näher hier der turner des wetters rückt
immer näher das war event alter der
regie des guten
mich hat er auf ein halbherziger gut
wird zu gehen
ja mich hat auch ein halbes ehrlich die
gmk ich hatte keine lex aber wenn ihr
irgendwelche wobei der da hilfen
wahrscheinlich auch tipps von zuschauern
nicht fassen aber irgendwie ist es so
dass ich kann ich es beschreiben ich
wahrscheinlich gleich mal eine aufnahme
noch mal es ist einfach so ich hab ganz
normales internet wirklich erst auf dem
handy zum beispiel kann man es am besten
beschreiben
ich bin in mein zimmer komplett normales
internet drei balken liedern drei balken
wlan bleibt stehen also ich hab das ist
gar nicht so gewesen
ich dachte das wärs du dir hatte exakt
das gleiche equipment aber direkt hinter
mir auf jeden fall ich habe immer noch
ein wlan steht da aber internet denn ich
komplett ganz ich kann keine seite
aufrufen
überall steht verbindung fehlgeschlagen
nichts geht mehr nichts genauso sie als
auch am pc ist nur noch nicht so schlimm
das komplett weg sondern ich hab dann
normal lecks in pink von 500 oder so
aber komplett ohne grund und dann nach
zwei minuten kann es wieder gehen oder
halt auch nicht und es wird immer
schlimmer und ich wir haben neun unter
ausprobiert da ist hat nichts gebracht
wir haben
es liegt einfach unser leistungs wird im
moment eine andere leitung verlegt noch
irgendwie seitdem haben wir diese
hässlichen problem ist nicht nur bei uns
in unsere nachbarn sondern die auch
deswegen ich dachte schon das leck in
das ärgerlich ich konnte gerade mit den
wegbrennen skills des todes überleben
nämlich kein schwert obama anfang unter
direct klatscht aber jetzt hab ich halt
jetzt und verteidigt auch gut weil wir
spiel minecraft eishockeyspiel navarro
auf 18 klasse macht ihr die kills im
chat wie viel ware auf 18 und gerade da
ist ja ping so wichtig und deshalb ist
das echt 1 punkte also mehr als bei
einem 7 weil dieses blog hätten so was
wieder entfernt wurde oder andere sagen
auf die animation ist anders auf jeden
fall haben diese ganzen die eine ahnung
davon haben in der konfiguration ehrlich
ich hab den einen runtergerechnet der
ist so weit gedacht kann der andere hat
nicht abgestorben der neue alte der
komplette box pocket gehen eine runde
gehen wir mindestens noch ja also das
ist wirklich problematisch weil
vielleicht müssen wir uns da irgendwas
einfallen lassen was weißt du wieviel na
wenn man nebenbei skype kannst du das
klicken
ansonsten könnte man meinen
ansonsten könnte man ja irgendwie über
über handy zocken oder sowas über das
internet aber es kannst ja knicken
daneben auch im teamspiel aber vor allem
über handy lte waro zocken ist zwar habe
ich über krasses internet dann aber wie
viele schon als meine blättern auf das
hält ja nicht ich kann nicht aber nicht
fünf paare fragen mit aufnehmen
das stimmt wurde ich habe eine umrüstung
jemand mit voller rüstung gemacht ich
bin also schon klubs für mich zwei kids
er wollte erst mal sich selbst zu recht
auch ja so langsam auch ab törns ist mir
alles nicht mein freund
ich boxe einfach schon mal dass immer
wenn man sagt also nicht knapp sondern
akteuren dann denke ich immer so an was
schlecht ist weil abtörnend sehr
negatives im sinne von abb macht kaum
hört doch mal auf deshalb hast dich cool
es gehe nämlich eigentlich so viele
menschen eine neue runde gehen
deshalb hatte ich eigentlich kurs geht
das ist vollkommen random eigentlich so
wer hat am anfang schnell sachen krieg
oder halt am besten ab stoff er kann man
eigentlich dieses dieses bootes bis tour
kann man dieses welche anderen
geschrieben
leider ist es zu viel für mich
was soll ich denn jetzt sagen
irgendwas habe ich an gesäß mit kann man
dieses nein jetzt gestoppt schon wieder
jemand ab nein ich loslaufen gold jetzt
wieder alles fragen wurde kann man
dieses getränk pvp zu zweit spielen
irgendwie es gibt aber in diesem wohl in
diesem pvp modus gibt ja kein game halt
da kannst du dich hoch arbeiten mit
kasse rüstung kassenschalter das kann
man ja auch unendlich halt team das
richtige abfahrt weil doch manchmal auch
relativ hacker die daten sind an einer
stelle stehen geblieben hatte haben so
was halt auch mega lustig und vor allem
taktisch das können auch mal aus spaß
machen ja stimmt der gun game ist so
auch für die für die roskill es gar
nicht schlecht
das leben oder neun spieler ich freue
mich so ich hoffe es geht jetzt noch
schnell lässt danach die inseln für mich
aufnehmen machen wir heute gehe ich weg
hört haben auch ihr seht ja sogar direkt
an wenn ich nicht gegen etwas betrüblich
dann eines tages werde ich entscheiden
müsste dann entscheiden wenn sie nicht
martin n
dies lenke ich jetzt mal dein video
ok ich glaube es ist das internet das
internet
ich dachte ich hätte etwas falsches
gesagt aber entschlossen das hört dann
schreibt er bestimmt die kommentare
martin ja so viel zu wir nehmen gleich
sind für ihn auf ich werde es probieren
hier nochmal mein bestes zu geben ab
dies natürlich in der teams erlaubt
runde konzentration als inflation egal
meine sachen wer tieren etwas regen oder
vielleicht gerade ausgehalten
naja junge leute das war durchsetzte
aufnahme sie hat aber cool angefangen
und dann ja ok aber es war viel
verspannt und behindert und tschüss